hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen kürbis rezept und
zwar bis zum snacken machen und ich freu
mich schon richtig sehr und dieses
rezept denn ich liebe kürbismarkt
fischernetze gerne und häufig sogar
daran hindern kürbis rezepte dieses jahr
zu machen aber ich habe eine umfrage bei
den zuschauern gemacht bei facebook und
viele wünschen sich kürbis rezepte heut
mach ich dass meine hokkaidokürbis aber
es kommt definitiv noch ganz viele
rezepte mit anderen kürbissorten auch
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
hefeteig brauche ich einen hokkaido
kürbis 500 gramm mehl einen halben
würfel hefe zwei esslöffel wasser 80
gramm zucker 125 milliliter milch sei
etwas vanille extrakt einen teelöffel
salz und 80 gramm weiche butter nehme
jetzt erstmal den kürbis und dem muss
ich jetzt zu einem püree verarbeitet
das heißt ich schneide ihn jetzt erst
mal klein das erste mal bier
jetzt gebe ich denke bis in einen großen
topf und wertet jetzt erst mal zur ruhe
verarbeiten das heißt ich muss es einmal
weich drucken mit etwas wasser gibt doch
kürbispüree fertig zu kaufen
aber ich finde es ist wirklich super
schnell hergestellt und vor allem ist es
jetzt mehr als ich später brauchen
werden ich kann dann später auch
aufbewahren das zeigen durch gleich
jetzt kommt ihr wasser mit dazu und zwar
müssen die kürbis studie ist vollständig
bedeckt sein
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf und dann
dauert es etwa 20 minuten bis der kürbis
weich ist und ich werde dann den herd
auf mittlerer stufe stellen
der kürzeste zwei ich gekocht und jetzt
gebe ich ihr hohes gefäß und bei denen
gleich kurieren
komplette story wirklich jetzt oder 25
gramm ab so brauche ich nämlich für den
teig und dann wirklich gleich noch ein
bisschen was für die füllung ab und den
rest kann ich jetzt gleich aufbewahren
das kürbispüree und die flüssigkeit
könnte jetzt weiter verwenden und zum
beispiel eine suppe kochen oder discos
pury auch würzen
habt ihr so wiesen kürbis stammt oder
gibt es jetzt in so eiswürfel behälter
und könnte dann ein film und dann bei
bedarf einfach immer wieder auftauchen
ich werde jetzt hier einfrieren in
mehreren portionen und dann einfach in
eine große schüssel umfüllen sobald sie
eingefroren sind
ich steck das jetzt ab und stellt erst
mal zur seite bis es abgekühlt ist auf
zimmertemperatur eingefroren und so in
diesen 15 bildern hat einfach den
vorteil dass ich später die einzelnen
kleinen würfelchen nehmen kann nun
einfach portionieren kann zum beispiel
für eine suppe für püree für noch mal
einen kuchen oder auch zum beispiel für
babys also für die babykost jetzt kann
ich den hefeteig zubereitet
dafür nehme ich jetzt den würfel hefe
unglück liefen
da kommt wasser mit dazu und etwas
zucker und das wird jetzt erst einmal
verrührt jetzt lasse ich diese hefe
mischung einfach fünf bis zehn minuten
stehen
da kann nämlich das kürbispüree auch
abkühlen und die hilfe kann man schon
mal so ein bisschen aufgehen die hefe
gut aufgegangen hat so kleine bläschen
an der oberfläche und jetzt kann ich ein
hefeteig zubereitet und gewitzt einfach
nur noch alle zutaten in einer
küchenmaschine oder können das ganze
natürlich auch mit den händen verkneten
es kommt dann noch den mädels mit dazu
festlicher zucker etwas vanille extrakt
natürlich für den geschmack das sei
und deshalb jetzt gebe ich hier auch das
lauwarme kürbis püree mit dazu und es
sorgt an dem hefeteig natürlich auch für
die tolle farbe also nicht nur für den
geschmack sondern auch für die farbe und
ich hab jetzt den kleinen vorteil
gemacht
ihr müsst ihr nicht machen ihr könnt
denn auch weglassen und könnt gleich
alle zutaten weiter verarbeiten also
ohne die hefe aufgehen zu lassen
aber es hat den vorteil dass es hilfe
gewechselt ein bisschen aromatischer
wird und ich kann natürlich auch weniger
hefe benutzen und das hefegebäck bleibt
länger frisch
es kommt auch die butter mit dazu jetzt
wird der hefeteig für etwa sieben bis
acht minuten geknetet bis sie schön
weich elastisch ist und einfach nicht
mehr abschlüsse landkreis
der hitter gesetz verzichtet und jetzt
nehme ich ihnen heraus dass es schön war
ich aber wirklich nicht mehr kleben dann
gebe ich sie auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche
und da freue mich ihn jetzt zu einer
kugel zusammen und geben jetzt wieder
zurück in die schachtel mit ein bisschen
mehl und muss ihn dann erst einmal
ausgesetzt für etwas 60 minuten ausgehen
lassen und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
aber schon mal die füllung vorbereiten
für die füllung brauche ich zwei
teelöffel butter 2 äpfel eine
unbehandelte zitrone zwei teelöffel
zucker ein viertel teelöffel ingwer
einen teelöffel zimt etwas muskatnuss
und 150 gramm kürbis püree
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die äpfel und die
werden jetzt einige würfe dafür entfällt
jetzt das kerngehäuse und die haut also
die schallplatte es einfach dran
jetzt gebe ich die butter in einem topf
den habe ich jetzt bereits erhielt und
da kann ich jetzt die apfelstücke ein
bisschen warten und jetzt auch gleich
zitronenschale wie dazu
den zucker gebe es jetzt auch mit rainer
kann der so ein bisschen karamellisieren
jetzt gebe ich noch den zitronensaft mit
rein
der bringt noch ein bisschen säure mit
rein weil er doch der hefeteig und auch
der gus später so ein bisschen süße sind
auch die gewürze mit dazu und auch die
muskatnuss
und das ganze lasse ich jetzt bei
mittlerer hitze so etwa fünf minuten
einkochen
den habe ich jetzt ausgestellt sind wir
jetzt hier noch das kürbispüree mit ein
und da muss sich die füllung jetzt
erstmal abkühlen lassen und war auch
bisher hilfe tag ausgegangen ist und
dann geht es gleich weiter
der hefeteig gesetz gut ausgegangen und
wir werden zu einer großen sind schnecke
formen denn ich habe mich gerade dazu
entschlossen da machen doch nur eine
große party musste dabei einmal
aufräumen ausrollen und das aufrollen
also ich bin die farbe vom teig wirklich
super schön jetzt wird der zunahme um
großen rechteck ausgerollt mit etwa 50
mal 60 zentimetern
darüber verstreiche ich jetzt die
abgekühlte füllung
und wir schneiden jetzt diese platte in
3 cm breite streifen das geht entweder
mit einem pizzaschneider oder zum
beispiel mit dem bissig let da kann ich
mehrere auf einmal schneiden
bz der fahrer wird
jetzt soll ich den ersten teil streifen
ganz eng auf so das geht jetzt auch
recht einfach
und der wird jetzt hier in die mitte
gestellt und die restlichen halbiert
herzen bisschen einfacher geht
jetzt nehmen wir immer einen teig
streifen und legt einfach noch mal drum
herum dass am ende eine große schnecke
entsteht
und die farbe umschließe jetzt mit einem
back ring und zwar deswegen damit diese
schnecke später einfach schön rund
bleibt und die form behält so deswegen
am außenrum legen um stammen so ein
bisschen fest 10
und jetzt werde ich ihn abdecken und
nochmal für etwa eineinhalb stunden
aufgehen lassen befreunden backofen
kommt der hefeteig ist jetzt schon
aufgegangen und jetzt seid die große
zelt im backofen bei 180 grad hitze für
etwa 30 minuten gebacken und in opel
sich bereits vor geheim
die kürbis zum backen und ich habe
selbst fünf bis zehn minuten abkühlen
lassen und jetzt werde ich noch ein
topping machen
ihr könnt jetzt entweder ein puderzucker
zitronen topping machen was
geschmacklich auch sehr gut passen würde
weil einfach die throne so frisch
schmeckt ein bisschen die säure mit
reinbringen oder ihr macht sich ein
karamell topping und zwar ohne stadt
diese drei zutaten ich habe 50 gramm
braunem zucker zwei teelöffel butter und
fünf esslöffel sahne
jetzt gebe ich die den braunen zucker in
einem topf und der wird jetzt
karamellisiert und hin nämlich jetzt
brauchen da eben viel aromatisch
schmeckt als normalerweise zucker
sobald der zucker jetzt geschmolzen ist
gebe ich die butter mit rein und sie
auch den topf vom herd herunter damit
einfach nicht verbrennt
jetzt kommt da die sahne mit rein und
die sarah weiß nicht mehr eiskalt aus
dem kühlschrank damit einfach das
karamell jetzt nicht klumpt jetzt muss
ich einmal noch kurz aufkochen lassen
und dann ist truppen schon fett
jetzt sind die karamellsoße und pizarro
die schnecke ist jetzt fertig und murat
steht schon in den startlöchern möchte
probieren ja ich bin auch sehr stolz
auch probieren wie es auch probieren und
steht und steht im kader stehen
jetzt heißt es also ich finde auch für
sitzt auf jeden fall schon mal ein super
aus und geschmacklich wird es dir auch
schmecken murat denn ich meine so
richtig cool aus ketsch und es ist so es
gibt so viele leute die angst auch für
kürbis jetzt irgendwann aber eigentlich
kenne ich natürlich immer angst ich weiß
nicht ich glaub ich hab mal mehr mit
kindern kürbis glaube ich weiß nicht was
es war schon eine türkische
spezialitäten
vielleicht hast du schon mal wieder so
richtig weich auszeit liebt ist
hier seht ihr jetzt diese ganzen
einzelnen schichten
es wird ja so drumherum gewickelt und
dadurch wird es jetzt einfach so
voneinander fallen also beim essen so
lecker
die farbe ist einfach der hammer kann
man die kamera bitte es ist so wichtig
weil mit einer gabel alles zerstört und
äpfel sind muskatnuss was habe ich noch
mit training war habe ich mit drin
irgendwann kann man gerne etwas matter
ein bisschen also ist es schmeckt
wirklich super geschmeckt den geschmack
wohl nie habe es ja weil irgendwie dem
parlament ja und kürbis kann absolut
möglich absolut ich finde allem allein
optisch ist total der renner
und es ist ja wirklich sehr einfach zu
machen und dieser kuchen darin geht es
mal anders aus weil es auch fast so dazu
falls technik wie schmeckt so richtig
weiß bei also ich finde man schmeckt es
schon her leicht raus ich weiß nicht was
ich meine kindheit schief gelaufen ich
weiß es auch nicht ich werde es
vielleicht noch raus bekommen hat jetzt
auch lust bekommen hat auf diesen
leckeren krisen auf diese riesenkürbis
zimtschnecken dann schaut auf zdf.de das
steht noch mal das rezept für euch und
natürlich können der falls ihr seht
nicht an einem stück machen wollt auch
ganz viele kleine machen und das ganz
normal wie so eine art schnecke machen
bekanntschaft in parameter auch letzte
mal zu belassen
genau das habe ich ja auch schon gesagt
am ende also ein bisschen säuerlicher
passt auch sehr gut aber es passt
wirklich beides super
wobei ich finde optisch passt karamell
schon ideal
schmecken ist wirklich schmeckt dabei
nein ich muss nur fotos danach alles
klar
viel spaß beim nachhaken bis zum
nächsten mal machst du überraschen
lassen